good afternoon everyone
on behalf of the department of the
interior
i'm very happy to welcome you here to
lake mead
and to say thank you
vice president harris and members of the
nevada delegation for being here today
to witness the effects of climate change
firsthand
this morning we heard directly from our
experts about the effects of climate
change and of the drought on our water
supplies
we heard
as well that we have
tools in place to help respond to the
the drought and help make sure our
communities can remain resilient to
climate change
we are very concerned about the
conditions that may be facing us in the
future
we know that it is important for our
generation to take on the task of being
able to address what may come next and
to develop the next round of agreements
that will help us get through
so that we can continue to thrive
we have tools available to conserve
water and plan for droughts
but we need to do more
the buildback better agenda
will help us
to make sure that we have those tools it
will it contains the valuable
pieces that will let us do even more and
more and more
thank you again vice president harris
and
we look forward to
continuing to work with you close
closely we appreciate the strong support
that we have from congress as well and
i'm happy to introduce representative
titus
well thank you very much and thank you
to the department of interior and its
great representatives who work on this
i'm so honored to be able to show the
natural beauty but also the results of
climate change to our vice president
thank you so much for being here you
know several things are going on at once
we're in the fastest growing cities in
the country we have two and about 2.25
million people and 40 million visitors
we're also the warmest community in the
country and third we have the smallest
allocation of water from the colorado
river
nonetheless we have been great stewards
and we have reduced our consumption by
45 percent but it's going down down down
even further and that's why
the provisions that address water
conservation and climate change
generally that are in the buildback
better bill and the infrastructure bill
are so critical this is our moment you
hear the existential argument look
around at this bathtub ring it's very
clear so thank you madam vice president
for being here and taking this message
back to
[Music]
washington well good afternoon i'm
stephen horsford and i'm proud to
represent nevada's fourth district
and to join with my colleagues to
welcome the vice president back to
nevada and to be able to show her first
hand
the effects of the drought and the
implications of climate change you know
growing up
here in las vegas
i've had the opportunity to enjoy lake
mead
as a as a kid growing up
and now as an adult bringing my own
children out here to fish this summer i
was sharing that with the vice president
but we have built
a
desert in the middle
we have built an oasis in the middle of
a desert and las vegas really has relied
on the water from lake mead that
unfortunately has dropped uh
considerably over the last decades
because of the effects of climate change
and that is why
we support and we know congress must act
to pass both the bipartisan
infrastructure bill as well as the build
back better act and its provisions to
protect and address the needs of our
environment and
climate change so we look forward to
continuing to work with your leadership
madam vice president and of course the
president and thank you for taking the
time to come and see this firsthand and
working with our entire delegation in
nevada
climate change is not
a partisan issue this is an issue that
democrats republicans and independents
understand must be addressed
and now is the time for us to act so
thank you madam vice president and i'll
turn it over to congresswoman susie lee
good afternoon it is my honor to welcome
the vice president to congressional
district 3 on the shores of lake mead
for 86 years lake mead has provided the
true promise that it is to our community
not only is it our recreation outlet for
many not just nevadans but tourists from
across the world it also is a source of
hydropower and a source of our water
and water is life and when we look at
lake mead it represents the lifeblood of
this community and that's why the steps
that all of the incredible staff that
gave us briefings today
doing on conservation have been so
incredibly important and but the work
that we are doing in congress led by the
vice president and president with the
bipartisan infrastructure package which
includes my water recycling bill which
will mean that we reserve water for milk
thousands of families in southern nevada
for years to come
but not only that the build back better
agenda will take on climate change head
on
and ultimately when we look to the
future that's the type of leadership we
need and so
i am proud to work alongside this
administration
to you know we say climate change is not
tomorrow it's today and when you look at
the ring here in lake mead we all
understand far too well what it means
and so with that it's my honor to
introduce madam vice president kamala
harris
congresswoman titus thank you for the
warm welcome and for your many years of
leadership on this issue in the united
states congress uh
congressman hortsford you so eloquently
talked about the the intergenerational
impact of this issue and will continue
to be an intergenerational impact and
i've spent time with you in your
district and know of your long-standing
leadership on this issue even before you
entered congress and congresswoman lee
thank you for the warm welcome to your
district and for your leadership and and
the invitation to join you
um here today
so this is
a fundamental issue which is the issue
of water
literally the issue of water as the
congress members have mentioned
every living thing
depends and requires on water and its
existence and its prevalence
and what we are seeing in this nation
and around the world is that this
climate crisis
fueled by in
many if not most ways by human behaviors
has resulted in the moment where we're
looking at this beautiful american
landmark
the product of a lot of thought over
generations about how we can supply
in particular the states of nevada
arizona california and including mexico
with the water that 25
25 million people rely on
this is such a fundamental issue
and so when we talk about the buildback
better agenda it is an agenda let's
break it down what is buildback better
what does it build better agenda it's
about climate
it's about families
and it's about jobs
and so and it's about health
and all of these issues are present when
we look at the issues that are impacting
lake mead as an example of what is
happening around the country
not to mention the fact that right now
all of all the western states
90 percent
of the western states are facing some
level of drought
so when we look at what's happening here
we know this is about this lake but it
is about a region it is about our nation
the build back better agenda
is thoughtful and forsightful and it
really is transformational in the way it
will address these issues so on the
issue of the drought the infrastructure
the bipartisan infra infrastructure deal
combined with the buildback better
agenda is about what we need to do to
invest in things like water recycling
and reuse
what we can do in terms of water
desalination
what we can do in terms of
implementation of drought contingency
plans
this is about thinking ahead recognizing
where we are and where we're headed
if we don't address these issues with a
sense of urgency
understanding this is literally about
life
on the issue of jobs the bipartisan
infrastructure deal as was mentioned
during our our tour
will be about good union jobs the work
that needs to be done to help us build
up resiliency adaptation and also combat
the climate crisis that's about the jobs
that are about
pipefitters electricians
plumbers these are good union jobs that
are about restoring
our
basic infrastructure upon which we rely
for these fundamental needs
on the issue of climate well the build
back better agenda will help us tackle
the climate crisis with investments in
clean energy and electric vehicles and
so we can reduce emissions and why do we
need to reduce emissions because that is
part of what is contributing
to these drought conditions
so this is the work that we are talking
about with these two bills that are
before congress
and it is critical that we as a nation
understand that we have within our hands
within our possession the ability to
actually change the course of where
we're headed
just look out at this lake
look at
where the water has receded
over just the last 20 years
that space is larger than the height of
the statue of liberty in just the last
20 years
this is where we're headed
so let's take on a sense of
responsibility with a sense of urgency
and do something about this
in a way that is about satisfying basic
needs which in this case right here is
25 million people
who are served by what happens at lake
mead
not to mention what we can do that is
about future generations
so let's get these bills passed let's
understand that right now we have a
moment
where we have the ability
to actually
benefit future generations and be
transformational
in a way that will not only
be about life but about
this beautiful planet and beautiful
places like lake mead thank you all